en cuisine anthony s'attaque au turbo du
poisson frais de ce matin car dans ce
restaurant on ne cuisine que des
produits frais et du fait maison on
travaille au fil des saisons si c'est la
seconde urbains ont trahi le turbo le
rouge et on travaille dur où j'ai alors
on va rentrer dans la lotte et le rouget
on va changer un peu nos produits quoi
le fait maison un thème qui se retrouve
dans toutes les bouches ces temps ci les
15 grands chefs du collège culinaire de
france ont lancé le 8 avril une
appellation restaurants de qualité le
but rendre plus visibles les restaurants
qui proposent des produits frais et
cuisinés sur place mais avant cette
nouvelle appellation n'y avait-il donc
aucun moyen de savoir ce qu'on nous
servait dans nos assiettes des labels
existait déjà comme celui que détient la
maître des lieux isabelle maîtres
restaurateurs même pour nous
professionnels s'est pas séparé ans
c'est quand même une reconnaissance et
beaucoup de travail beaucoup d'énergie
c'est le travail de toute une équipe
donc on est quand même assez cher un
label d'état difficile à obtenir
les critères portent notamment sur une
cuisine fait-maison des cuisiniers
diplôme et la fiabilité de la
traçabilité des produits et sur un
contrôle important un audit notamment
quand l'appellation restaurants de
qualité valide sur dossier et sur la
note des clients alors au premier abord
quand isabelle a appris la nouvelle elle
ne l'a pas tout de suite vu d'un très
bon oeil pourquoi alors commis nous
sommes maîtres restaurateurs on n'en
parle jamais ou quasiment jamais
pourquoi d'un seul coup du casse mais à
faire ça est-ce qu'il en a vraiment
besoin qu'elle en quelle on est leaders
favard et grosse médiatisation dessus
donc a priori mauvaise impression et
puis finalement en réfléchissant bien je
pense que tout ce qui peut nous servir
en terme d'image je pense que c'est
positif tout ce qui peut mettre en avant
la bonne nourriture c'est important une
appellation médiatisé et qui ouvre le
débat sur la transparence
pour la confédération des professionnels
indépendants de l'hôtellerie c'est bien
ce point qui importe mais selon elle le
fait maison n'était pas économiquement
se généraliser est ce parce que beaucoup
d'opérateurs dans la restauration et
surtout les petites et moyennes
entreprises de la dette de notre métier
pratique ce qu'on appelle la cuisine
différé ou même l'externalisation de
tout ou partie de leur production bon
bah parlons-en il n'y a pas de tabou là
dessus mais c'est vrai que dès qu'on en
parle on est immédiatement montré du
doigt comme étant des gens qui préconise
la malbouffe qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la malbouffe jure que le premier
opérateur de cuisine de restauration
commerciale en france s'appelle
mcdonald's ils ont mille 300 restaurants
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
les gens avons pas manger des hamburgers
c'est la contrainte ils y vont parce que
ils y trouvent leur compte laisser le
choix aux consommateurs c'est bien ce
que souhaitent tous les acteurs le
collège de france aura au moins réussi à
mettre ce problème sur la table